least that thought of like
this is going to be hard for us we can't
do this
and they stay there and so
i would agree obviously i would agree
with that quote like there
there are things that just happen in the
world that
we can't control and it's just a lasting
effect like you were saying earlier with
the tax bracket there's effects to
there's effects to anything and
everything that you do whether it's good
or bad
but in that
i feel like you have to
if it negatively affects you how can you
bounce back if it positively affects you
okay how can you
take that and run with it
yeah i agree
and that's what eventually led me away
from it
[Laughter]
you can do
[Music]
um no it's just like um
i think that
i don't wanna
i know
so
i i like having like conversations like
this with the other side
because i'm interested i'm interested to
see just to hear like what
what are
your thoughts about
like this
yeah the effects okay it's more like of
course there's going to be effects like
that that happened for
how long i don't think 400 years yeah
but it's more like what can you do about
it you can't you can't do anything about
it now like in 2022 so the only thing
you can do is try to be bet like
make right going forward i don't think
like like they'll talk about reparations
and stuff okay so reparations um
i've seen on a lot of videos like when
when the law was passed that
there
no slavery abolished it
there were we were supposed to well not
the slaves were supposed to get uh 40
acres of meal and i remember asking my
mom like who agreed on that why 40 acres
in a meal and she like was telling me
like well back in the day 40 acres you
had your own land and a mule you were
able to
put crops and be able to um
plant and
have have land to do that and so
now i've seen people calculated like
well if we go back and we
talk about we get the 40 acres enemy and
then like they calculated like what else
would we get now and like
um
what's the word um
when interest
they've taxed interest on it and they're
like
we're old like a lot of money i'm like
if that was true today
i would be a a rich person if we got
reparations so
um
i don't know if that's possible or if
that's
ever going to be a thing
but
so okay so
the the problem with reparations is what
what percentage of white people do you
think actually owned slaves
in the u.s
i don't
i don't know
it's less than one percent
really yeah
and the other problem is money doesn't
solve poverty
if money solved poverty then like people
could just throw money at a poor person
and they'd become rich but we're lottery
winners
they're like they go broke faster than
anyone because they don't know how to
spend it yeah it's about like managing
money and being able to run a business
like i think reparations possibly at the
top like at the time
but you can't
like like how you're making people that
didn't do anything pay for something
their great great great grandparents did
even if you did the direct descendants
like most people immigrated here after
slavery
like my like i have a grandparent from
lithuania or a great grandparent oh
you're saying that
okay i thought okay like and you have to
understand even and then what about the
white people that fought on the other
side that fought against yeah
so it's it's almost like like i just
don't know how that would work it's like
you're i understand what you're saying
it's like you're grouping
everybody
all the white people together when it's
like um my my descendants did have
nothing to do we were
we were elsewhere when all this stuff
was happening okay i could understand
that yeah
and so i just i just don't know how they
would do it in a way that would like
make sense
like back then sure sure and then you
have to understand like how many people
really owned plantations that was really
only the super rich people in the south
they everywhere
what i said you go in the south they're
everywhere no i know but who owns them
that's what i'm saying like it's not the
majority of people back then yeah most
people lived in the north like because
you have to think about how many
like that was a lot of land so you had
to be a landowner yeah so that's like
the one percent back then okay
so i'm glad you said that i got my mind
thinking it's not bad
it's not no it's not the internet
scares me a little bit
but it's it's good to have this
conversation like people want
people want like
to have these conversations but it's
like they're not
open enough to be able to sit down with
someone and say this is my opinion on a
hard topic like slavery this is my
opinion it's like well how can you say
that when this and thermo it's like i
just want to hear what your thoughts are
and then you get me thinking and i get
you thinking it's like okay i never
thought of it like that because if we
honestly if we did have
reparations today i think a lot of a lot
of black people would be out of tough
situations but i also think
a lot of black people put themselves in
worse situations because they don't know
how to manage money and if like the
first steps if they were like okay we're
going to give you reparations but you
have to go through
a class where it teaches you how to
properly manage your money because once
it runs out
we ain't giving you no more i mean
nothing and so i think that would be
a great first step to be able to if if
reparations was a thing
to be able to
help
the black community i just i don't see
government handouts helping like
a little bit right i think like maybe
initially but it i don't see evidence
that that's super helpful because you
take
the homeless population how many of them
are using that 600 a month to like
pocket or
invest in something like over a certain
age i think if you're
if you're homeless like you you've made
choices to get there and i have
relatives that are homeless and the
reason they're homeless is because
they've stolen from every family member
that's let them
like live with them
and then nobody wants to take care of
them anymore and now they're homeless
and i know maybe like a lot of people
are gonna say like that's i i come from
a very privileged position and i totally
do
but i just think you know you get out
the house at 18 if you're 45 and still
in that situation you did something
wrong the past 20 years you couldn't
have been good with money yeah
yep i agree with that wholeheartedly
because i have conversations with my
family like if we're in the same
situation next year we did something
wrong like if
you're if you
are put into a position and you
there's steps to where you can change
your situation but you don't decide to
change it that means you don't want your
situation to change at all yes there may
be obstacles in the way you may have to
jump through some hoops it may be harder
but
i feel like
everyone has the opportunity to change
their situation well it's kind of like
you right like why are you doing this
youtube channel right now because you
showed up on time
and you were helpful and so i said like
come on and now and now i pay you to
come on
right so it's like that's an opportunity
that you got because you showed up on
time
yeah and helped out early when no one
else was really helping
and so that's what like i i just i kind
of have a pessimistic view of people in
general i think most people like
don't show up and they don't try
and like and i think you can see it in
the us at least because most people get
overweight over time yeah and that's
that's a direct indicator of how much
you try
i think
you think that's wrong
i don't know if it's a direct
indicator
because
i'm trying to like think
i think it's
a source yeah one of them right of them
yeah it's like discipline on some level
because i've been over 200 i've been big
and it was because i wasn't trying hard
enough at losing weight
it's just an indicator that
like you said discipline you don't have
discipline